is it
this week we are launching the Alesso
heist which is a collaboration with the
DJ music producer les Oh who's also made
a track called payday so the highest is
taking place at a huge arena in
Washington DC what's so special about
this place is that one of the floors is
filled with a lot of vaults that are
really really difficult to to open best
way of doing this is to blow up the
vaults from beneath and what's so unique
about this heist is that Alice's music
is integrated with the gameplay so
players have to time the explosions with
specific parts of the concert
the vision with payday was to create a
track that really pumps up the
adrenaline and make you you know what to
be focused and just you know keep it
going and have that energetic feeling to
it it's just amazing to be a part of
something like this I am a big gamer
myself and to be able to put my music
and create something for something else
like this action video game it's just a
great opportunity for me and I think the
track combined with the game create
something really unique I'm really
excited about it
I really feel that this was a really
cool thing to work with and the guys at
Star breeze does one of them a job so I
hope you guys like the game in the track
the heist is coming out to 21st of May
it's a stealth and loud heist it's one
of the biggest heists we've done so far
and we really hope you guys will enjoy
it
you